>> A ONCE BOOMING ECONOMY HAS
NOW TAKEN A MAJOR HIT DUE TO
LOCKDOWNS IN THE COUNTRY.
AMERICAN LIVES, BUSINESSES HAVE
BEEN PLACED ON HOLD FOR MONTHS.
THE NEW YORK CITY MAYOR, CONRAD
BILL de BLASIO NOW PLEADING
FOR FEDERAL ASSISTANCE.
$9 BILLION WORTH.
OKAY?
NOW HE ALSO SPENDS MONEY ON THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND ALL SORTS
OF WASTED MONEY, $900 MILLION
THAT HE AND HIS WIFE ARE
INVOLVED IN.
WE AS AMERICANS CANNOT AFFORD TO
BAIL OUT GOVERNORS FOR THEIR
OUTRAGEOUS SPENDING.
REMEMBER, LIKE A LIGHT BULB
FACTORY AND, OH, MICROCHIPS AND
A SOLAR FACTORY.
IF YOU ASK ME, YOUR BEST
STIMULUS PACKAGE, AMERICANS
REOPENED DOORS, OUR BUSINESSES,
FLOOD THE ECONOMY BEGIN TO HEAL
AND WE LEARNED A LOT OF LESSONS,
WE SHOULD NOW IMPLEMENT THEM.
OUR NEXT GUEST HAS SOME
DIFFERENT IDEAS AND HE IS THE
OWNER OF THE MAVERICKS, THE
DALLAS MAVERICKS.
HE IS PROPOSING A USE THAT WORD
WAS THAT DEBIT CARD PROGRAM TO
BOOST CONSUMER CONFIDENCE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
>> LET ME TELL YOU, YOUR MATH
SEGMENT WAS INVALUABLE.
>> NOBODY IS DISAGREEING ON WHAT
HAPPENS.
I THINK I MIGHT ACTUALLY WANT
SPORTS MORE THAN YOU.
WE ALL WANT TO RETURN TO
NORMALCY.
BUT YOU ARE A BILLIONAIRE.
THE REASON ARE, AMERICANS ARE
CRAVING NORMALCY.
IF YOU TAKE CARE OF THE ELDERLY
LIKE YOUR GOVERNOR DID, THEY
DIDN’T REALLY COME UP REALLY
WELL PROTECTING THE MOST
VULNERABLE.
STUPID DECISIONS.
THEY PUT COVID-19 PATIENTS IN
NURSING HOMES, AND THAT WAS
THIRD OF ALL THE DEATHS.
>> EVERYBODY MADE THEM PERFECT
DECISIONS WITH IMPERFECT
INFORMATION.
NEW YORK CERTAINLY MADE MISTAKES
BUT SO DID EVERYONE, LOOK AT
OTHER PLACES THAT HAD MEAT
PROCESSING PLANTS WHERE 20% OF
THE POPULATION IS NOW STRICKEN
WITH COVID.
IT’S HARD TO DEAL WITH IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IT’S HARD TO CAST THE BLAME AND
NOT.
>> Sean: ALL THE MODELS AND
PREDICTIONS WERE WRONG.
BUT, ALL THOSE WHO REMAIN
CONSISTENT, PROTECT THE ELDERLY.
THEY WERE TELLING THEM, WE CAN’T
HANDLE THIS.
PROTECT THE ELDERLY.
ALSO IN THE EPICENTER OF THIS, I
CAN’T ARGUE WITH THAT AT ALL.
AND THAT’S A GREAT REASON TO
WEAR A MASK.
>> Sean: I LIKE IDEAS.
I DON’T CARE WHERE THE IDEA
COMES FROM, BUT YOU SAID, USE IT
OR LOSE THAT DEBIT CARD.
AND WHAT, $101,200, YOU HAVE A
CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME TO
STIMULATE THE ECONOMY.
THE PROBLEM IS WE SPENT
$3 TRILLION, ANOTHER TRILLION IN
LOAN GUARANTEES.
THE COUNTRY CAN’T AFFORD THIS,
WE HAVE TO REOPEN.
>> I’M NOT SAYING WE DON’T
REOPENED BUT THE QUESTION IS,
AND I WILL EVEN PUT THE HIT ON
THE DEMOCRATS.
WHEN THE PPP PROGRAM WAS
INITIATED, IT WAS A GREAT PLAN
BUT THE KEY TO MAKE IT WORK WAS
GETTING THE MONEY IN THE HANDS
OF BUSINESSES IMMEDIATELY.
SO WHEN THE DEMOCRATS STARTED
OVER NEGOTIATING, THAT CREATED A
DELAY AND THAT MEANT THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES HAD TO LAY PEOPLE OFF
OFF.
ONCE SMALL BUSINESSES LAID
PEOPLE OFF, AND THAT NOW LEAVES
SMALL BUSINESSES IN THE STATE OF
SUSPENDED ANIMATION.
THEY ARE NOT OPEN ALL THE WAY
YET, THEY DON’T HAVE ALL THE
DEMAND BACK, AND 68% OF THEM ARE
MAKING MORE MONEY AND
UNEMPLOYMENT.
SO WHAT WE NEED TO DO IN ORDER
TO CHANGE THAT, IS TO STIMULATE
DEMAND.
THE WAY TO STIMULATE DEMAND IS
TO GIVE PEOPLE CHECKS THAT THEY
HAVE TO SPEND.
THE OTHER WAY IS WHETHER A STATE
IS OPEN OR CLOSED, THE ONLY WAY
THAT THEY CAN JUSTIFY AND AFFORD
TO BRING EMPLOYEES BACK
PARTICULARLY AFTER JULY 31ST
WHEN THE ENHANCED UNEMPLOYMENT
RUNS OUT IS BY HAVING DEMAND.
SO RIGHT NOW, PEOPLE ARE SAVING
14.4% OF OUR INCOME AND THUS THE
MOST IT HAS BEEN IN 40 YEARS,
THAT’S A PROBLEM WE NEED TO
SOLVE.
>> Sean: HERE’S MY LAST
QUESTION.
YOU CAN HAVE THESE TEMPERATURE
CHECK TURNSTILES, AND I’M NOT
TRYING TO DISCRIMINATE.
WE CAN ASK OLDER PEOPLE FOR THE
TIME BEING TO STAY AWAY FROM
STADIUMS COME OUT FOR STADIUMS
TO START.
YOU COULD GIVE EVERYONE A
DALLAS MAVERICKS MASK OR YANKEES
MASK, PATRIOTS MASK, WE HAVE
ROBERT KRAFT ON.
AND SAFELY OPEN THAT WAY.
WHY WOULDN’T WE TRY THAT BASED
ON THE LESSONS WE LEARNED FROM
THE KIDS THAT WAS STOCKING THE
SHELF EVERY WEEK?
>> ONE THING, THE TEMPERATURE
CHECKS DON’T WORK BECAUSE YOU
CHEW UP A COUPLE OF EXTRA
STRENGTH TYLENOL AND YOU DEFEAT
THE SYSTEM.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND HOW WE DO
IT ON SCALE.
IT’S NOT LIKE A GROCERY STORE
WHERE YOU LET ONE OUT AND LET
ONE END, IT’S A LOT HARDER WHEN
YOU HAVE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
GOING IN.
>> Sean: THEY HAVE THESE
TURNSTILES WHERE YOU WALK RIGHT
THROUGH.
YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT THE TIME,
BUT COULD WE ACTUALLY LOOK OUT
FOR OUR NEIGHBORS?